as of today I believe you're 37 years
old you're going to be 30 day on the 38
on Wednesday I believe right yeah
your birthday's coming up so as a 38
year old if you uh become the president
I mean that's the youngest president
we'll ever have in the history of
America currently the President Biden's
80 President Trump is 77 and what would
it mean for your country what do you
think would mean to America for us to
have a president that's 38 maybe next
year be 39 years old why do you think
there's that enthusiasm to want to get
somebody that age as a president
so here's what I will say
I'm the youngest person ever to run for
U.S president in a major party
here's what I'll say is going on in the
country
I understand my generation I'm a
millennial
people younger than me gen Z
what's going on
we are hungry for a cause that's what's
going on
we are starved for
purpose
and meaning and identity
at a time in our National History a
moment when the things that used to fill
that void
Faith patriotism hard work
family
these things have disappeared
and that leaves a black hole a moral
vacuum in its wake and when you have a
black hole that runs that deep that is
when the poison fills the void
it almost doesn't matter what the poison
is actually and this is where
conservatives even myself at times in
the last three years we get too wrapped
up in the symptoms
woke is of transgenderism climatism
covetism
globalism
but it's not just politics or culture
depression
anxiety fentanyl
suicide
you think it's an accident that we see
the rise of these different poisons
right at the same time in American
history it is not a coincidence guys
it is a symptom of a deeper void of
purpose and meaning so honestly Patrick
I do think people are hungry for a
different generation of leadership but
to tell the truth there are people my
age who you know may be less with it
than some people who are 80 or 90 years
old who I know who are good for them
sharp is attacking with it I don't think
that's quite it it's not just that we
need a young person
I think what we need is we need to fill
that vacuum by as I said before not just
running from something but running to
something the left will give us this
vision of race gender sexuality climate
and then the right will just criticize
each of those things and say okay well
here's what's wrong with that without
offering a vision of Our Own
and so what I'm saying in this race is I
want us talking more
about what we stand for
the value of each individual the value
of this thing we call the Family
the nation
God actually there's a whole the size of
God in your heart and God doesn't fill
it something else will instead the same
can be said for belief in a nation
we're like a bunch of
blind bats actually I don't mean to get
too philosophical tonight but
it's it's the visual that comes to mind
for me
we human beings we're like blind bats
we're lost in a cave
a bat can't see where it is it sends out
sonar signals that bounce back and says
this is where I am
well we human beings we do the same
thing we send out a signal that bounces
off of my family the two parents who
brought me into this world that's true
that's real
bounces back it says this is where I am
send out a signal it bounces off of my
belief in God my conviction in this
nation these things are true they bounce
back they say this is where I am I work
hard you're an entrepreneur I'm an
entrepreneur we work hard we create
something in the world that is real that
is true I am proud of that that is real
that comes back
says this is where I am
well what happens when those things each
disappear
we send out these signals
and then nothing comes back
right we're lost in that Wilderness and
so
I think that's what young people are
hungry for and we've told them for a
long time
go to Ben and Jerry's and order a cup of
ice cream with some social justice
sprinkles on the side and make yourself
feel good and and that works for a
little bit
but you can't really satisfy a moral
hunger with fast food it works in the
short run but I think right now we're in
a place where that effect is fading I
think people are hungry for the real
thing whatever that is
I think that's actually what's
resonating it's not my age or anything
else but as a member of my generation I
get it I was disaffected from politics
for a long time
I didn't vote from most of my 20s I
voted when I back when I was 19 for the
libertarian candidate I wasn't inspired
by the political candidates I saw I was
disaffected myself so I get it
I understand that
but I think now is Our Moment to level
up and say we're going to fill that void
with an actual vision of what it means
to be a citizen of this nation
and if we can do a good job I'm doing my
best in this race if we can do a good
job of offering a Clear Vision for young
people for all people across this
country
I think we're going to see a domino
effect I think where Harris trigger away
from a national Revival even though it
might be hard to see today
that's truly where I think we are and
I'm actually genuinely optimistic that
we're not
a nation in Decline
I think we are
still as hard as it might be to believe
a nation
in our Ascent actually
in the early stages of our Ascent maybe
I'm not the only young one maybe maybe
our nation is itself a little young
actually
going through our own version of
adolescence
figuring out who we're really going to
be when we grow up and then it makes
sense because when you go through
adolescence
you go through that identity crisis you
go through that self-doubt that's where
we are but I think we're going to get to
our adulthood on the other side of it
and I'm in this to play my small part to
help lead us there so that's kind of how
I think about it I I appreciate that so
let's just say you're on stage and you
remember the uh the the moment with
President Reagan when he's debating and
he says I do not want to make this
debate about the lack of experience my
opponent possesses right okay so let's
just let's just visualize is it
president Trump's already announced he's
not going to do the first debate right
he's just not going to do it he's going
to let everybody else knowing him he may
matter of fact you think he's going to
show up I have no idea I'm cool either
way so so let's just say he doesn't show
up and he's saying everybody competes to
be possibly my VP that's kind of how he
put it but let's just see on stage with
them not the first one second third one
say you're on stage and he looks at the
camera and says listen do you really
think America is ready for a 38 year old
young guy half my age the amount of
experience I've had the people I've sat
down with this guy's great he's
phenomenal he can play a role on Mike
cabinet he's going to say that but you
are way too young to be the president do
you think America today
prefers somebody in their mid to late
70s or somebody in their late 30s
I think the country is ready for a new
generation of leadership I've got fresh
lights
[Music]
[Applause]
excited for this I mean I hope my best
days in life are still yet ahead of me I
mean for me November 2024 that's not the
destination that is the start line
the destination of the presidency is
January 2033 when I leave office
my older son won't even be in high
school yet
I think it might take somebody whose
best days are still ahead of him I hope
they are God willing
to see a country
whose best days are ahead of itself as a
nation and that's that's how I genuinely
see it
do I have the level of experience that
President Trump has on foreign policy or
on leaving the federal government no by
definition I've not been in government
but one of the things I might say is
I actually think I am in some ways
closer to Trump in 2015.
then Trump today is to Trump in 2015.
actually
you know eight years from now I might be
tired jaded cynical have a few extra
pounds and a little bit gray a little
gray throwing through my hair if I have
any hair left and you know we're human
beings right you go in to drain the
swamp the swamp drains part of you
and I bear no illusions that this is
gonna be some hunky-dory job no this is
going to take something out of me
it would out of every person who's been
through it and I get that
but I guess I'd rather have somebody
going in that still has fresh legs
that's going to come out of it not
completely drained on the other side but
move to a new phase of my own life as
this country moves to the next phase of
its National Life and so are the people
ready for a young person that's not for
me to say my job is to tell you who I am
and what I stand for that's your guy's
job what do you think one
okay so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]